Just a quick question for pro choices.
How would you feel if your parents wanted to unalive?
Men are, like,
shockingly unhelpful. Like,
women are suffering and dying from abortion bans.
Abortion bans have increased the infant mortality rate,
and they're out here like,
your hypothetically a fetus
and your parent wanted to hypothetically abort you,
how would that make you feel?
It's like our healthcare and our lives
and the consequences of these actual policies are very real,
and you're out here having some type of, like,
thought experiment,
hypothetical philosophical debate with yourself or another guy.
In my comments the other day was like,
I'm here fighting for all the future women who don't have a voice.
It's like there's women in front of you right now who have voices,
and we're trying to talk to you,
and you just keep ignoring.
I, like,
you can't even help the ones right in front of you. I just.